au canada on n'oblige pas les
producteurs de boissons alcoolisées à
afficher une liste d'ingrédients
d'enlever on signale toutefois la
présence de sulfites mais aucun des 50
autres ingrédients qu'on pourrait y
retrouver au moins depuis 2016 on peut
connaître la teneur en sucre de notre
vin préféré
en alimentation le sucre est devenu au
fil des ans unis ni à contrôler et à
consommer avec modération
ingrédient essentiel dans bien des
produits il ne fait pas exception dans
le vin c'est très important pour les
questions de santé de savoir si vous
êtes en train de boire de sucre en extra
des arts qui a été un des premiers
chroniqueurs à faire pression auprès de
la saq afin qu'on affiche les taux de
sucre dans le vin
j'ai rencontré plein de monde dédié
bêtes qui sont en train de boire des
vins qui dans ce temps là il y avait
plein de vins très très très sucré vin
rouge très sucré sur le marché puis
avait aucune idée que le vent était
sucre et puis j'ai demandé à la sécu de
suivre les lcd au printemps qui avait
quand même mis le taux de succès le site
web j'ai poussé j'ai poussé j'ai poussé
puis finalement je pense que ç'a pris un
an et demi mais ils on est allé un petit
peu plus loin que même j'ai demandé ils
ont mis sur les étiquettes
le sucre contenu naturellement dans le
raisin est à la base même de la
fermentation
c'est le sucre qui se transforment en
alcool le jus de raisin compose
essentiellement de sucre qu'on peut
qualifier de fermentescibles et de sucre
non fermentescibles donc le succès
remonte et sims est par exemple le
glucose et leur frutos alors que les
soutenons fermeté c'est pour vous
retrouver le galactose l'exil aux
annonces et d'autres également ce sont
des sites naturellement présent dans le
fruit oui notamment en grande quantité
comme l'illustrent aux mains il est de
ceux qui sont présents mais en petite
quantité dans le jus de raisin quand
même
lors de la fermentation du vin ces
sucres fermentescibles seront
transformés en alcool par les levures il
reste donc qu'à la fin du processus une
certaine quantité de sucre communément
appelée sucre résiduel
l'un est inscrit à la base le sucre il
aime ça alexandre st pierre est un
importateur et représentant 20 des vins
les plus vendus au québec étaient plutôt
des vins à ces industriels ou parfois le
degré sexy aussi élevé et probablement
voulu est bénéfique pour le côté
gustatif
c'est quand même un peu comme en cuisine
qu'en qu'il manque un peu savard en
rajoute un peu de sous pour un peu de
sel en donc des vins plutôt industriels
qui avait vraiment un avantage à mettre
fin aux tentures effectivement en 2013
par exemple parmi les meilleurs vendeurs
à la saq ont trouvé le ménage à trois et
haptique raid de vin rouge californien
avec des taux de sucre résiduel de 13 et
17 grammes par litre et le sauvignon
blanc 2 km kraft foods à 6,6 g par litre
les vins les plus vendus à la saq et est
au sucre et le rose et le plus vendu au
québec contenait 40 grammes par litre et
cinq ans plus tard on se retrouve avec
un meilleur vendeur qui ce qui est à
moins de 2 grammes par l'ue qui se
rapproche plus de 1 g par le un grand
changement c'est en effet opéré dans les
habitudes des consommateurs
la demande pour des vins secs est
devenue la norme plusieurs producteurs
ou même adapter leurs produits le ménage
à trois est passée de 13 à 4,3 g ou
litres entre temps ses ventes ont chuté
il ne figure plus parmi les 50 meilleurs
vendeurs à la effectué
ce qui s'est passé au cours des quatre
cinq dernières années on a vu un marché
qui a été complètement chamboulée par
l'affichage en tablettes du gramme par
litre en fat32 teneur en sucre une foire
20 qui avait une tolérance 8 de 2
grammes par litre il ya eu une erreur au
niveau de l'affichage tablette qui était
affiché à 5.7 et les ventes ont baissé
d'un coude à peu près 30 à 40% la sueur
sur quelques mois une fois que ça a été
corrigé ça a pris quelques semaines
quelques mois et c'est revenu un peu
plus à la normale
les gens vont entrer en succursale et
demandé j'aurais besoin d'un vin blanc à
2 g de secret - ou un rouge à 4 de
secret - cinq ans à matha savard ont une
importance j'espère que les anciens
aussi 20 sec pour des goûts personnels
dont les cherche simplement pour
résoudre son nombre de calories ou
diminuer sa consommation de sucre ça
vaut pas tellement la perdre
l'éléphant dans la pièce au niveau d'un
verre de vin c'est pas le succès
vraiment l'alcool dans un verre standard
de 140000 et litres de vin il va quand
même avoir 13 points 45 grammes d'alcool
chaque gramme d'alcool apporte cette
galerie donc dans un verre de vin vous
partez des jeux avec un petit peu plus
que 90 calories donc je prends un vin
par exemple à 4 grammes par litre de
sucre je vais acheter à peine quelques
lequel riham envers ce qu'on affiche
c'est une concentration par litre mais
il faudra mener toujours un verre qui
est à peu près 140 millilitres le sucre
résiduel a quand même son importance
dans certains vins tout est une question
d'équilibré
le rôle du sucre dans le vin si on parle
du style classique c'est du vrai bois de
travailleur équilibré l'acidité
riesling d'allemands ou de niagara où ce
que tu vas avoir des x 10 15 20 g de
sucres mais s'il n'était pas là
l'acidité votre tellement tellement
tranchante que ça va être un buveur sûr
si vous avez un problème de diabète
c'est simple bon le moins de ceux qui le
moins d'alcool que passer si c'est une
question de santé devaient pas boire
dire et c'est je préfère dire aux gens
de risques vous année buvait ce qui est
bon plutôt que d'arriver des lots de
sucre parce que il faut choisir un vin
en fonction de ce qu'il est en fonction
de son terroir en fonction de ce qu'il
est et non pas en fonction de son taux
de sucre nécessairement
le combat n'est pas terminé pour been
donc tout ce qu'on met dans notre corps
tout ce qu'on mange on a le droit de
savoir qu'est-ce qui est dans ce sens là
on a même une poule calories dans ça
pourquoi pas le vin et puis je pense que
peut-être les gens qui regardent tous
qu'est ce qui m'a payé et qu'est ce
qu'ils boivent qu'est ce qui met dans
son corps et peut-être ça c'est vraiment
le gros changement maintenant
[Musique]